The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general,
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: For me, this is
the third and last major topic
of the course.
The first one was initial
value problems -- stability,
accuracy.
Topic two was solving
large linear systems
by iterative methods and
also by direct methods
like re-ordering the equations.
Now, topic three is a whole
world of optimization.
In reality it means you're
minimizing or possibly
maximizing some expression.
That expression could be a
function of several variables.
We could be in the discrete
case, so we've got --
maybe I just emphasize that
we have discrete optimization.
So that's in R^n,
discrete in n dimensions,
and that will include some
famous areas as single,
as small subsets, really,
of the big picture.
For example, one subset
would be linear programming.
So that's a very special but
important case of problems
where the cost is
linear, the constraints
are linear, and has its
own special methods.
So I think that's worth
considering on its own
at a later point in a lecture.
Another bigger picture
-- for us, actually,
bigger will be quadratic
programming where the quantity
that's being minimized
is a quadratic function.
Now what's good about
a quadratic function?
Its derivatives are linear.
So that leads us to
linear equations,
but always with constraints.
We don't have a free choice
of any vector in R^n.
We have constraints on the
vectors, they have to --
maybe they solve a linear
system of their own.
We might be in 100
dimensions and we
might have 10 linear equations
as the unknowns have to solve.
So in some way we're really in
90 dimensions, but it might --
you know, how should we
treat those constraints?
Well, you know that Lagrange
multipliers play a role.
So there's a big area, very big
area, of discrete optimization.
Then, also, there is
the continuous problems
where the unknown is a function,
is a function u of x I'll say,
or u of x and y.
It's a function.
That's why I refer to that area
as continuous optimization.
Well, first, you
always want to get
an equation, which is
in some way going to be
derivative equals zero, right.
When we learn about minimization
in elementary calculus,
somewhere along
the line is going
to be an equation
that has something
like derivative equals zero.
But, of course, we have to
account for the constraints.
We have to ask, what is --
the derivative of what when
our unknown is a function.
I'm just going to write down
a topic within mathematics
that this is often expressed as.
Calculus -- that
would be derivative.
But in the case
for functions it's
often called the
calculus of variations.
So that's just so
you see that word.
There are books with that title.
The idea of what is that
derivative when our unknown is
a function and the objective
that we're trying to minimize
is the integral of the
function and its derivatives --
all sorts of
possibilities there.
So that that's a very
quick overview of a field
that we'll soon
know a lot about.
I was trying to
think where to start.
I think maybe it
better be discrete.
I want to get to the
system of equations
that you constantly see.
So let me use, as an example
the, most basic problem which
comes for -- maybe
I'll start over here --
the problem of least squares,
which I'll express this way.
I'm given a matrix A,
and a right-hand side b,
and I want to minimize the
length squared of A*u minus b.
So that would be a
first problem to which
we could apply calculus, because
it's a straight minimization
and I haven't got any
constraints in there yet.
We could also apply
linear algebra,
and actually linear
algebra's going
to throw a little extra light.
So, just what am I
thinking of here?
I'm thinking of A as being m
by n, with m larger than n.
If A is a square matrix,
then this problem is the same
as solving A*u equal b.
And, of course, we'll
always reduce to that case
if m equals n.
But to focus on the problems
that I'm really thinking about,
I'm thinking about the
case where this is the --
n is the number of unknowns.
It's the size of u.
m, the larger number, is
the number of measurements,
the number of the data, so
it's the number of equations,
and it's the size of b.
So we have more
equations than unknowns.
You've met least squares before.
I hope that maybe even in these
few minutes, a little new light
will be shed on least squares.
So here's our problem,
and calculus could lead us
to the equation for the best u.
So, u stands for
u_1, u_2, up to u_n.
There are n components
in that vector, u.
Maybe you know the equation
-- I guess I hope you know
the equation, because it's such
a key to so many applications.
If I just write it, it will
sound as if problem over.
Let me write it though.
So the key equation -- and then
this comes up in statistics,
for example.
Well, that's one
of 100 examples.
But in statistics, this is
the topic of linear regression
in statistics.
Let me write down -- they
gave the name normal equation
to the equation that
gives u directly.
Do you remember what it is?
The normal equation?
The equation for the
minimizing u, which
we could find by calculus?
It involves the key matrix A
transpose A. Let me call u hat
the minimizer, the winner
in this competition.
The right-hand side of the
equation is A transpose b.
So I won't directly
go back to derive it,
though probably I'm going
to end up deriving it,
because you can't help
approaching that equation
from one side or another.
As I say, one way to
approach it would just
be to write out what that sum of
squares is, take its derivative
and you would get
linear equation.
So again, u hat stands for
the u that gives the minimum.
This A transpose A, of course --
so I'm putting in a little bit
of linear algebra.
This matrix A transpose
A is obviously symmetric.
Its important property,
beyond the symmetry,
is that it's positive definite.
Well, I have to say
positive definite --
there's always a
proviso, of course.
I haven't eliminated
the degenerate case yet.
A has m, many, many rows, a
smaller number of columns,
and let's assume
that those columns
are linearly independent so that
we really do have n unknowns.
If those columns were, say if
all the columns were the same,
then A*u would just be
multiplying that same column
and there would really
be only one unknown.
So I'm going to say that
A has rank n, by which I
mean n independent columns.
In that case, that's
what guarantees
that this is positive definite.
Let me try to draw
an arrow there --
this is the same statement.
If I say about A that the
columns are independent,
then I'm saying
about A transpose A
that it is positive definite.
That means all its
eigenvalues are positive;
it's invertible, certainly;
all its pivots are positive.
It's the great
class of matrices.
But I don't really want to
start with that equation.
Here's my point.
Optimization -- a key word
that I better get on the board,
maybe up here, to show
that it's really important,
is plus the idea of duality.
The effect of duality, if
I just give a first mention
to that word, is that very
often optimization problems,
there are really two problems.
Two problems that
don't look identical,
but in some important
way they both,
each problem is a statement
of the task ahead of us.
What are the two problems,
the two dual problems
in this basic example
of least squares.
All right, here's
a good picture.
Here's a good picture.
Let me put it on this
board so I can recover it.
So, minimize A*u minus b.
So I think of the
vector b as being --
where it's in m dimensions.
So it's a picture -- I'm
in m dimensions here.
Now, what about A*u?
A*u -- where will A*u
go in this picture?
So, A*u is -- all
the candidates A*u,
multiply A by any vector u, so
that means A*u is a combination
of the columns of A, the
possible vectors A*u lie
in a subspace.
So this is the subspace of
all possible vectors A*u.
And it's only n-dimensional.
This is an n-dimensional
subspace because I have only n
parameters in u,
only n columns in A.
So the set of all A*u's
I think of as a --
you could say a plane, an
n-dimensional plane within
the bigger space R^m.
Another name for that
subspace, that plane, is the --
in 18.06 I would call it
the column space of A,
or the range of A is another
expression that you--.
All the possible
A*u's and here's b,
which isn't one of
the possible A*u's.
So where is u hat?
Where is the best A*u
-- the best A*u now?
The one that's
closest to b is --
now comes another central
word in this subject.
If I draw it, I'm
going to draw it here.
That will be my best A*u,
which I'm calling A u hat.
That's the -- if the picture
seems reasonable to your eye,
this is the vector that's
in the plane closest to b.
What's the geometry here?
See, that's what
I wanted to see --
a little geometry and a little
algebra, not just calculus.
So the geometry is
that this vector b,
what's the connection
between b and that vector --
that's the closest
vector, right?
We're minimizing the distance.
This distance here, I might
call that the error vector e.
This is as small as possible.
That's being minimized.
That's the difference between
-- this is Pythagoras here.
Of course, when I
say it's Pythagoras,
I'm already saying the
most important point,
that this a right angle here.
That's a right angle.
The closest A*u, which is A
u hat, which is this vector,
the way geometrically we know
it's closest is that the line
from b to the plane, that's
where the line from b,
perpendicular to the plane.
This line, this error vector e
is perpendicular to the plane.
There's a good word that
everybody uses for this vector.
Take a vector b that's
not on a plane, what's
the word to look for the
nearest vector in the plane?
AUDIENCE: Projection.
PROFESSOR: Projection.
So this is the projection.
Orthogonal projection,
if I wanted
to really emphasize the fact
that that's a right angle.
So that would give
me a geometric way
to see the least
squares problem.
Now comes the point to
see the dual problem.
The dual problem will be, here,
if I draw the perpendicular
subspace.
So that's a subspace
of what dimension?
This contains all the vectors
perpendicular to the plane.
So I have it as -- if m is 3,
so we're in three dimensions,
and our plane is an ordinary
two-dimensional plane,
then the dimension is one --
that's the perpendicular line.
But thinking bigger, if we're in
m dimensions and this plane is
n-dimensional, than
this is going to have --
the true dimension
of this is m minus n,
which could be
pretty substantial.
But anyway, that's the
perpendicular subspace.
If this is the
column space of A,
I can figure out
what vectors are
perpendicular to the columns of
A. That's really what I mean.
This contains -- I've
drawn it as a line,
but I've written up there its
dimension so that you see --
I just don't know how to
draw, like, a bigger subspace.
Yet you would have to see
that all the vectors in it
were perpendicular to
all of these vectors.
Do you see what I'm saying?
If we were stuck in thinking
in three dimensions,
if I make this a plane I
can't make that a plane.
If I make m equal 3, and
I make n equal to two,
I'm only got a line left
to be perpendicular.
But in higher dimensions there
are lots of dimensions left.
So what's my dual problem?
My dual problem is find
the vector e in this plane
closest to b.
In other words, by
the same reasoning,
what I'm saying is
take the vector b,
project it over to this plane,
project it orthogonally --
that same right angle
is going to be there.
This plane -- I haven't
said what's in this --
I've said what's in this plane
but I haven't written it yet.
But you could tell me already.
What is this?
What's that vector?
One answer would be,
it's the projection
of b onto this perpendicular.
So you see we're really
taking the vector b
and we're separating
it into two components.
One in the column space,
the other perpendicular
to the column space.
So just tell me
what that vector is.
It is e.
Same guy.
In other words, e is the
solution to the dual problem --
maybe I call this projection
p for the best vector
in the plane. e is the best
vector in this subspace,
and they add up to--.
So, we're really
taking the vector b,
and we're splitting
it into a part
p in this space, and a part
e in the perpendicular space.
If I just write down
the equations for that,
I'll see what's cooking.
Well, I guess what I have
to do is remember what
are the equations to
be in this subspace,
to be perpendicular
to the column.
So I can't go further
without remembering
what's in that subspace.
So everything in
that subspace is
perpendicular to
the columns of A.
Let me just write
down what that means.
Let me use the letter
maybe y for the vectors
in that subspace, and e for the
winning vector, the projection.
So y will be the vectors
in that subspace.
So those vectors
are perpendicular --
so this is the subspace
of y, all the y's in here.
Now, what's the condition?
So y -- that y in this
perpendicular subspace.
What do I mean?
I mean that y is perpendicular
to the columns of A.
How shall I write that?
Perpendicular means
inner product zero.
So I want to change
the columns into rows,
and take the inner product
with y, and get zeros.
Zero, zero, zero.
So, this is column 1
transposed, to be a row.
I'm trying to express
this requirement
in terms of the matrix.
So to be perpendicular
to the first column,
I know that means that the inner
product of the first column
with y should be zero.
The inner product with
the second column --
the second column
with y should be zero.
The n-th column, its inner
product with y should be zero.
So what matrix have I got here?
What's the condition on
y's, simple and beautiful?
What matrix is that?
It's A transpose.
So that perpendicular thing --
this is completely expressed
by the equation A
transpose y equals zero.
That tells me the
y's, and, of course,
e is going to be one of the y's.
It's going to be,
I could say y hat,
but I've already named it e.
It's the particular one
that's closest to b --
the y's are everybody
all along here --
this is the null
space of A transpose.
So in words, I would call it
that perpendicular thing is
the null space of A transpose.
So when you did linear
algebra, you'll remember that.
That the null space of A
transpose -- let me write it --
is perpendicular to
the column space of A.
The fundamentals theorem of
linear algebra right there.
Now we're just using
it again to see what
are the two dual problems here.
So the primal problem, the
one that we stated first,
was this one.
So I'll call this the
primal -- P for primal.
What is the dual problem?
The dual problem is the
problem about the y's.
Not about the u's at all.
That's the beauty
of this duality.
One problem is
about u's, and it's
a problem that ends up
projecting on the column space.
The second problem
is about y's, it's
the problem that
ends up projecting
onto this perpendicular space,
and it was a projection.
So the dual problem is just
minimize the distance from b
to y, but with the
constraint, with --
and now I get to use
that word constraint --
with A transpose y equals zero.
So there is the other problem.
So I hope your eye can
travel between the -- well,
let me write underneath
it the primal again.
Minimize A*u minus b square.
This is the one
whose solution is e,
and this is the one whose
solution is, well, u,
and the projection
-- u hat, sorry,
and the projection p is A u
hat, and I guess what I'm trying
to say is that somehow there's
a very important connection
between the two problems.
First of all, the two
problems use the same data.
They use the same vector b, they
use the same matrix A. Notice
that in one problem it's
A, and in the other problem
it's the transpose appears.
That's very common --
we'll see that always.
But there's something
a little different
about the two problems.
This problem was unconstrained,
any u was allowed.
This problem was constrained,
only a subset of y's, only
that subspace of
y's was allowed.
This is a problem
with n unknowns.
This is a problem with
m minus n unknowns.
m minus n unknown
variables, once we've
accounted for the constraints.
This is one thing
I'm thinking about.
Often, the problem will
come with a constraint.
Maybe I'll do a physical
example right away.
The problem comes to
us with a constraint.
In other words, suppose you
were given this problem.
How would you deal with it?
That's like the first
question in optimization,
or one of the central questions.
How do you deal
with a constraint?
If we minimize this,
of course, the minimum
would be when y equaled b.
But that's failing to take into
account the constraint on y.
So how do you take
constraints into account
and end up with an equation?
We can see, in this picture,
that somehow or other we
ended up with this
normal equation,
but actually I would rather end
up with a primal dual equation.
I'd like to end up with
an equation for the best
u and the best y.
So what will that be?
So I need now two equations
that will connect the best
u and the best y, and probably
this is going to be the key.
This b is A u hat, right.
So this will be one
of my equations,
and this will be the other.
Let me see if I -- well, OK.
I don't know what to do now.
Here I've called it y.
Over here it's e.
I've got myself in a corner.
Maybe I should call e y
hat, would you like that?
We have in mind that it's e,
the error in the primal problem.
But just to make the
notation for the two
problems consistent, let me
call the winner here y hat,
the winner here u hat.
What's the relation?
So let me just -- here I'll
write down the relation between
the two.
Well, it's over there.
Let's see, is that right?
Yes?
y hat plus A u hat is b, and
A transpose y hat is zero.
That's it.
Here we have -- that's the
pair of equations that solves,
that connects the primal and
the dual, solves them both,
solves each one, and is
really, it's a system --
you could say it's
a block equation.
The block matrix being
identity A, A transpose, zero;
the unknown being
the y and the u.
The right-hand side being
the data, which in this case
was the b.
I guess what I want
to do is emphasize,
in what's coming for
the month of April,
the importance of this
class of problems.
It's dealing with two --
it's dealing with the primal
and the dual at the same time.
It's important for so many
reasons I can't say them
all on the first day.
That would be a mistake,
to try to say everything
the first day.
But let me just say something
-- that linear programming,
which is just one example, and
it doesn't fit this because it
has inequality constraints.
But you maybe know
that the number one
method to solve linear program
is called the simplex method.
Well, it was the number
one method for many years.
For many problems it's still
the right way to do it.
But a new method called
the primal-dual --
at least that's part of
its name, primal-dual.
It is essentially solving the
primal and the dual problems
at once, and there are
inequality constraints,
of course.
I'm going to stop there
with linear programming
and give it its turn later.
In this perfect example
here, we have only equations.
How many do we have?
We have m plus n equations,
because y is m unknowns,
u is n unknowns.
I have altogether m
plus n equations --
m y's, and n u's, and
they come together.
Now, could you,
just to connect back
with what we absolutely know,
that it's a normal equation,
where is this normal
equation coming from?
So here's the normal equation.
We know that that's gotta
come, right, out of the thing.
How does it come?
Suppose I have a block
system, two by two.
How do I solve it?
Well actually, that's, in
a way, the big question.
But one way to solve it,
the natural way to solve it,
would be elimination.
Multiply this first row
by a suitable matrix.
Subtract from the second
row to produce a zero there.
In other words, eliminate y
and get an equation for u hat.
So what do I do?
How do I do it?
I multiply -- would you rather
look at equations or matrices?
I've tried to keep the
two absolutely together.
Let me look at the equation.
What shall I multiply that
equation by and subtract from
this -- I just
want to eliminate.
I want to get y hat out of
there and leave just an equation
for u hat that we will
totally recognize.
So what do I do?
I multiplying that
first equation by?
A transpose, thanks.
So I multiply this first
equation by A transpose.
Let me just do it this way.
Now what?
A transpose y is zero.
Now I use the second -- well,
this is one way to do it.
A transpose y is zero.
What am I left with?
The normal equation.
Well, it shouldn't
be a surprise.
We had to end up with
the normal equation.
Maybe you would rather
-- and actually,
what I intended was to make
it sound more like Gaussian
elimination.
Multiply this row
by A transpose,
subtract from this row.
I still have identity A up here
-- when I do that subtraction,
I get the zero,
that was the point.
Here I get A transpose
A subtracted from zero,
it's minus A transpose
A, y hat, u hat.
Of course, I had to do the same
thing to the right-hand side,
and when I subtracted this
the b was still there,
but it was minus A transpose b.
So, now I've got in
the second equation --
the second equation only
involves u hat, and, of course,
when I changed the
signs, it's our friend --
A transpose A u hat
equal A transpose b.
So this is -- maybe you would
say the natural way to solve
this type of system, but I want
to emphasize -- throw it away.
I really want to emphasize
the importance of these --
let me clean it back up
again to what it was --
of these block systems.
Now, they need a name.
We have to give some name to
this type of two-field problem.
I guess then, in
the next month, I'm
going to find examples
of it everywhere.
So here I've found the
first example of it
in ordinary old-fashioned
least square.
So what am I going to call this?
I'll call it -- I'll give
it a couple of names.
Saddle point equation,
saddle point system maybe
I should say.
I have to explain, why do I
call it saddle point system.
In optimization, I could call
it the optimality equation --
just meaning it's the
equations for the winners.
In the world of optimization,
the names of Kuhn and Tucker
are associated with
these equations --
the Kuhn-Tucker equations,
and there are other names
we'll see.
But let me just say for a
moment why saddle point.
Why do I think of this as
a saddle point problem?
See, the point
about A transpose A
was that it was
positive definite.
This is A transpose A.
Now what's the corresponding
issue for this matrix?
So this is my matrix that
I'm constantly gonna look at.
Matrices of that form are
going to show up all the time.
I've said probably in
18.085 where these appear
but then we don't
do much with them.
Now we're ready to do something.
I didn't appreciate
their importance
until I realized,
in going to lectures
on applied mathematics,
that if I waited a little
while that matrix would appear.
That block matrix.
It just shows up in
all these applications.
One of our issues will
be how to solve it.
Another issue that
comes first is what's
the general form of this?
Can I jump to that issue?
Just so we see something more
than this single problem here.
Let me put in the matrix as
it comes in applications.
Some matrix A,
rectangular, right?
Its transpose.
A zero.
Often a zero.
But what's up here is
not always the identity.
I want to allow
something more general.
I want to allow, for example,
weighted least squares.
So weighted least squares --
if you've met least squares,
it's very important to meet
its extension to weighted least
squares.
When the equations A*u equal b
are not given the same weight,
there's a weighting matrix,
often it's a covariance matrix.
I'm going to call the matrix
that goes in here C inverse.
So this will be then an
important class of application.
This is pretty important already
when the identity is there,
but many, many applications
produce some other matrix that
is usually -- it very, very
often is symmetric positive
definite in that corner,
like the identity is.
But key point, which
I have to make today.
Is the whole matrix --
either this one or this one.
It is symmetric, right?
That matrix is symmetric.
Is it or isn't it
positive definite?
If I do elimination do I
get all positive pivots?
It's a matrix of size m plus n.
So I'm asking, are all
its eigenvalues positive,
but I don't want to really
compute eigenvalues.
Also, in a lot of cases I would.
Finding the eigenvalues
of this matrix
would lead me to the
singular value decomposition,
absolutely crucial topic in
linear algebra that we'll see.
But let me just take
it as a linear system.
If I do elimination, what
are the first m pivots?
Let me not be abstract here.
Let me be quite concrete.
Let me put the identity here.
Let me put some matrix -- oh,
I want the matrix here to be --
I better put a bigger identity
just so we see the picture.
Here I'm going to put to an A
transpose, which might be 2, 3,
4; 5, 6, 7 -- when I
write numbers like that
you'll realize that I've just
pick them out of the hat.
Here is the transpose,
2, 3, 4; 5, 6, 7.
Here's the zero block.
I'd like to know
about that matrix.
It's symmetric.
And it's full rank.
It's invertible.
How do I know that?
It's the invertibility
-- of course,
the identity part is great.
I guess I see that this is
invertible because I've ended
up with A transpose A, and
here my A has rank two --
those two columns
are independent.
They're not in the same
direction -- [2, 3,
4] is not a multiple
of [5, 6,  7].
That's an invertible matrix, and
this process finds the inverse.
Elimination finds the inverse.
It's the pivots I
want to ask you about.
What are the pivots
in this matrix?
So what do I do?
The first pivot is a 1 -- I use
it to clean out that column.
The second pivot is a 1 -- I
use it to clean out that column.
The third pivot is a 1 -- I use
it to clean out that column.
What's the next pivot?
What do I have -- of course, now
some stuff has filled in here.
What is actually
filled in there?
So this is the identity,
if I can write it fast.
This guy is now the zero.
This guy didn't move.
What matrix filled in here?
Well, just what I
was doing there.
Elimination is exactly what
I'm repeating with numbers,
what I did there with letters.
What's in here is
minus A transpose A.
I could figure out what
that -- I could do --
if I was fast enough, I could do
2, 3, 4; 5, 6, 7 times 2, 3, 4;
5, 6, 7 and I'd get this little
two by two matrix that sits
there.
With a minus sign,
and that's the point.
That the pivots -- of course,
what's this first number going
to be?
4 plus 9 plus 16.
29 is that number.
So a minus 29 sits right there.
That's the next pivot.
The next pivot is a
negative number, minus 29,
and the fifth pivot is negative.
So what I'm seeing
is a matrix --
this matrix has three
positive pivots,
and two negative pivots.
I sort of say that
was a saddle point.
Positive pivots describe for me
a surface that's going upwards.
This surface is going upward.
I'm a surface in
five dimensions here.
It's going upwards
in three directions,
but it's going downwards in two.
The point at the heart
of it, the saddle point,
is the solution to our
system, is the y hat, u hat.
Well, one conclusion
is that I wouldn't
be able to use conjugate
gradient methods,
for example, which we've just
learned how powerful they
are, on the big matrix because
it's not positive definite.
It's symmetric.
I could use some other
available methods.
I couldn't use
conjugate gradient.
So if I wanted to use
conjugate gradient,
I better do this reduction
to the definite system.
That's longer than I intended
to spend on the simple example.
But if you see that
example, then we'll
be ready to move it to the
wide variety of applications.
So let me just note that one
section, already up on the web,
called saddle point systems,
solves differential equations
that are of this kind.
So we'll come to that, and we'll
come to matrix problems too.
It's a very, very
central question,
how to solve linear systems
with matrices of that form.
In fact, I guess
I could say it's
almost the fundamental problem
of numerical linear algebra,
is to solve systems that
fall into that saddle point
description.
I'll try to justify
that by the importance
I'm assigning to this
problem in the next weeks.
OK.
Thanks for today and
I'll turn off volume.